foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
walk away from the laborious NGS Library
prep introducing avinio Edge system
this webinar is a part of the sixth
annual laboratory automation virtual
event I'm Anthony nasalcito of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event with help from Andy Ching of Roche
sequencing
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
Roche sequencing for more information
about Roche sequencing please go to
sequencing.roche.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby
I now present today's speakers Terry
Mueller field applications consultant at
Roche sequencing and life science Scott
Burrough senior automation support
scientist at Roche and Andy Chang
marketing manager at Roche
a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Perry Scott and Andy
you may now begin your presentation
hello and welcome thank you for joining
us today my name is Andy Chung I'm the
marketing manager supporting NGS
automation at Rose sequencing and life
science
as many of you know Library preparation
is a important and essential part of NGS
workflow but no matter how streamlined
the library prep protocol is it is just
not fun to do is laborious time
consuming and it requires a lot of focus
to not make any mistakes
so that's why lab automation has become
a great solution for NGS Library prep
but automation also comes with its own
challenges as well learning how to use a
system developing new protocols keeping
up with all the hardware software
updates and maintaining the equipment
just requires a lot of effort and time
today we have invited two of our Roche
NGS experts to help us uncover some of
these challenges
we will also take the opportunity to
share more about our new Aveeno Edge
system and explain how it is designed to
overcome some of these challenges
but first please let me introduce our
NGS experts Terry and Scott
Terry Mueller is our field application
consultant who has been with Roche for
over 15 years Dairy has various NGS
applications and instrumentation
experience and has spent over 23 years
in a field of genomics
not Vero is our senior automation
support scientist who has spent over 20
years working in the field of NGS he has
developed NGS workflows and automating
them on various automated look Handling
Systems
it's great to have both Scott and Terry
to join us today Scott and Terry in your
careers you have supported many NGS
applications what are some challenges
you have seen and can you share some of
your personal experiences with us as
well
yeah thanks so much Andy
um I would say easily it's the amount of
Hands-On time that's needed you know a
lab tech is basically glued to their
bench for two days or more with only
small Windows of time to eat lunch or
even go to the restroom
yeah I totally agree that's why I
learned how to program liquid handlers
if more people would invest in
automation they'd quickly see that they
can process a lot more samples the same
amount of people which would allow those
people to go and work on other things
yeah but
automation up and running you need
someone who not only knows how to
program liquid Handler but also
understands the biochemistry right so I
seldomly come across a lab person with
both of those skills so now you have to
have two people devoted uh to that so
not to mention you also don't just need
the liquid Handler you also need a
thermocycler a magnet for the cleanups
the Shakers and then enough space to fit
all the plates and tips too
all true and this is the main thing that
people underestimate when they're trying
to build a process around automation
they think they can just go out buy all
the components put them together and
it'll just work but in reality it can
take half a year or more to finalize one
of these workflows
um so Terry besides reducing Hands-On
time what else have you seen in the
field that's a pain point for customers
trying to do these manual processes
I would say the next one would be just
people there are a lot of
a lot um and because everyone is running
around trying to get so much done it's
easy for technicians to get interrupted
when they're making a master mix or
pipetting into a plate which can of
course then ruin those samples and then
you can see quite a you know bit of
variations between technicians so one
might like to tip mix versus vortexing
and the amount of time that they do that
so that can cause a lot of variability
within the data
yeah uh again this is the great thing
about liquid handlers they can only do
what they're programmed to do
transfer volumes mixing shaking
incubation times they're all done the
same way every time
I do the same thing every time they want
to run a different number of samples
start or stop at different points change
them or PCR cycles and then second don't
you guys have to spend a lot of time
getting the liquid Handler to pipette
accurately or mix things well
yeah for this the second one first yes
we did initially have to spend a lot of
time working on the pipetting but
because we have so much experience we
can take all these techniques that we've
developed in the past and then apply
them to our current development products
projects and
it really really speeds up the whole
development process and then to your
first question about having variable
numbers of samples or start stop points
just like the pipetting experience that
we've built over time we've created
everything from completely lockdown
methods to methods that give users a
huge amount of control over all the
settings in the method what we found is
somewhere in the middle is really the
best spot to be we know that every Labs
process is a little bit different uh but
what we need to do is allow the right
parts of the workflow to have the
appropriate amount of control
but
this is the other big thing that's
underestimated building in this
flexibility is not only tricky but it
creates a lot of paths that a method can
take Each of which have to be then
verified so this adds a lot of time to
the development process and a lot of
expense to it
so actually Terry we do have a brand new
solution called The evinio Edge that's a
great example of everything we've been
talking about here Andy could you share
some information about the new system
thank you both for sharing your
experiences Terry and Scott I'm sure
many folks in the audience can certainly
relate to your stories and experience uh
you know doing ngsimple prep manually is
a way in the past to be honest but
automating NGS workflows is all too
often a privilege of labs that have the
automation expertise
it takes a lot of time to train new
users Implement long and complex
workflows that involves many device
Integrations and not to mention work
with multiple vendors uh sometimes while
under the pressures to meet all the
project timelines can be very tough and
this is why we're launching a new
product called the Aveeno Edge system
the video Edge system is a Class 1 IBD
system that takes purified DNA and
prepares the sequencing ready libraries
we launched this product earlier this
year and it is now commercially
available in the US it's fully enclosed
and integrated with all the necessary
devices needed for Library preparation
Target enrichment post capture pooling
and Library qualification all in one box
a venue Edge is quite unique in its kind
because it provides what we call a true
walk away experience to its users as we
know many automated workflow still
requires the users to be around and
frequently come back to the system
sometimes that's because not all the
devices are fully integrated with the
automated liquid Handler sometimes
certain steps just require a little bit
more of babysitting right making sure
the liquid Handler is doing what it's
supposed to do
on the venial Edge system for each
sample run only 20 minutes of manual
setup is needed
after the run starts the user can just
simply walk away completely and work on
other things without constantly thinking
about when and whether there's the need
to go back to the workbench
we have a short video that showcased
some of the key highlights of the video
Edge system and I'm going to play that
video right now and we'll come back to
discuss more about these features
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
as you saw in the video we designed a
video Edge to specifically address those
challenges around the traditional NGS
automation Solutions
Scott would you please take a moment and
share more about these features that we
just saw in the video
yes Andy I'd be happy to
full integration of a thermocycler
heater Shaker cooling blocks a
proprietary magnet position and an
onboard quantification module are the
key features that make this a truly
walkaway system
one power button turns the entire system
on including all the integrated devices
I just mentioned
based on the number of samples selected
for a run the integrated glove
compatible touch screen provides
step-by-step placement instructions for
each consumable
to ease instrument setup the tip and
reagent areas of the deck are on slide
out drawers and the instrument has
bright LED lighting
reagents are ready mixed and barcoded
preparing and dispensing Master mixes is
no longer required
all the plastic consumables are barcoded
pipette tip racks are bar coded as well
as color coded and partially used chip
racks can be left on the instrument and
used in the next run
at the start of each run the system
first scans all the barcodes to verify
the deck setup is correct and then
performs an additional physical
verification utilizing the pressure
sensitive capabilities of its spana head
to verify things like the microfuge tube
caps are removed and then we'll also use
its gripper to verify the plates are not
inverted and a barcode was unable to be
scanned
finally the built-in Control software
allows users to customize run parameters
such as amplification Cycles or
conditions ligation and hybridization
times and beat cleanup ratios
the software also provides a complete
log of the run for limbs integration and
it also records weekly maintenance and
has an integrated UV decontamination
option
thank you so much Scott to show how
avino Edge can truly transform users
experience we actually performed an
internal study to compare the Aveeno
Edge hyper cap workflow to our manual
Kappa hyper cap workflow as well as the
same workflow on two other open platform
automation systems as you can see here
on this graph a venue Edge only requires
14 manual steps compared to the other
workflows and this includes the
normalization of input samples DNA
Library prep Target enrichment using our
Kappa hyperact Zone panel library
quantification and post capture pooling
as a result as you can see on the right
here a venue Edge significantly reduces
the manual steps required for this
workflow and the opportunities for user
errors are also reduced by 91 percent
compared to the manual preparation and
by 88 compared to the other two
automation workflows
in the same study we also looked at the
Hands-On time required to complete this
workflow again this includes input
sample of normalization Library prep
Target enrichment Library Quant post
capture pooling as well as the time
required to clean up the workstation
after the sample run the graph here
shows a vino Edge only requires a 106
minutes of total Hands-On time and as
you can see here doing all that manually
or on the other automation platforms
require require a lot more time
in fact a vino Edge can help save over
nine hours of Hands-On time compared to
manual preparation and what's also
important here is that these hours of
time saved are uninterrupted
so a video Edge is a system designed
specifically to offer a refreshing NGS
automation experience in addition to the
product design we also want to leverage
rocha's experienced and extensive
support network to offer our users a
peace of mind for example Avenues Edge
instrument and all its integrated
devices software applications and even
reagents are all supported by Roche this
means an Avenue Edge user would no
longer need to work and coordinate with
multiple different vendors
the deployment or implementation of a
video Edge is also much faster compared
to the other traditional automation
systems installation takes about three
days there's no additional integration
Services needed because it comes with
all devices already integrated our field
application scientist would also provide
basic user training on site no prior
automation experience and knowledge is
required and this means potentially it
can get all set up and up and running
within just a couple of weeks
um and also the accuracy of pipetting
obviously is very important during the
NGS simple prep process our Roche
service team will ensure the entire
system including all the devices are
calibrated to their optimal conditions
pipetting verification is performed
during every video Edge installation and
prevent the maintenance service the
routine user maintenance is also very
simple and there's an on-screen
instruction for the user to to follow
very easily
so we believe a venue Edge system will
be able to help many Labs transitioning
away from manual NGS and overcome the
traditional challenges with lab
automation
if you have any questions about Avenues
Edge and what we talked about today
please visit
sequencing.rose.com
aveenoedge simply filled out a short
form and we will be more than happy to
further discuss with you
we also have a self-guided virtual tour
available for avenual Edge if you just
want to check it out and learn more
about these features we talked about
today
with that this concludes our session
today Terry and Scott I want to thank
you both again for joining me uh and
sharing your experience with us to all
of you tuning in thank you so much we
appreciate your time and interest and
have a great day
thank you Terry Scott and Andy for your
time today and your important research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today I'd also
like to thank our sponsor Rose
sequencing for sponsoring today's
webinar questions submitted today and
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until May 18th of 2024. lab
rates will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye